this lone wind turbine is located just
off the coast of hooks here on the North
Sea it's a solitary symbol of Germany's
planned shift to renewable energies and
a sign of what's to come a few
kilometers out to sea a wind park this
one is called me event or ocean wind and
supplies three hundred thousand
households a year with electricity but
before a wind park can be built
specially equipped ships have to scan
the sea bed every day weather permitting
a task force heads out on a salvage
vessel to make the North Sea safer
mine's torpedoes and grenades dating
back to the two world wars are still
lost in its chilly deaths heba cotton
for clapham scooby de he's into dumping
sites we know of are enormous there are
probably a million tons of munitions
polluting the North Sea in some areas
ammunition was thrown overboard on the
way to the dumping sites and aircraft
will also have dropped extra weight on
their return journeys to save fuel haha
after the end of the Second World War
when the Allies disarmed the Germans
they disposed of the weapons at sea
they've been there ever since the
saltwater corroding their metal sleeves
so that the explosives seep into the
water underwater robots like this one
can detect the munitions before they
possibly explode this could happen if an
asset fuse is activated by a chemical
process for example a diver is
dispatched to investigate this find
these experts do dangerous work defusing
bombs that can theoretically kill them
this object appears to be a naval mine
the diver has to be as careful as he can
and avoid sudden movements unsteady
hands could be fatal at this point in
the event that a bomb can't be defused
[Applause]
a controlled explosion is the last
resort if the munitions can't be
transported they're dealt with
underwater conservationists say
underwater detonations in danger marine
life seals fish and coral are often
killed by blasts I think of who you are
not God's eye down for boating about
think of the practice of dynamite
fishing which is thankfully being banned
haven't gone it killed fish with
underwater blasts marine animals have a
sensory organ along the side of their
body used to detect movement and
vibration in the surrounding water and
it also plays a role in their
orientation a blast causes pressure that
can kill fish the teams commissioned by
energy companies planning the wind parks
are aware of the environmental impact of
their work but they feel that clearing
unexploded ordnance in the North Sea
takes priority it's a threat to shipping
marine life and it's hampering Germany's
energy transition but the task force
also knows there's a limit to what it
can accomplish invisible body will be
more clearing all the munitions from the
North Sea could take another 20 years
making the coastal area completely safe
would cost millions and that's not even
taking the whole of the north sea and
Baltic into account that was they got
anticipation now over a million tons of
munitions were disposed of in the north
and Baltic seas after the Second World
War it's a dangerous inheritance